Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burn.
It's time for the Thursday afternoon.
Just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast and
just checking in on you.
I'm just checking in on you.
How's it going?
How's your Thursday?
How's your week?
You having a good time out there?
You're getting ready to eat your fucking face off.
Hey,
well,
here's a good one for you.
You know you're going to eat like an absolute pig on thanksgiving.
You know you're going to eat all the leftovers and all that crap.
You know you're going to drink your face off the wind the Wednesday before
Thanksgiving going out there,
right?
Trying to meet some ladies,
Going back to your hometown.
You know you're going to do all of that crap as ain't just the wind screen here
on the microphone.
Um,
you know,
you can do all that shit.
So why not?
Why not before?
Why not now?
Just you.
You do cardio every fucking day.
Giant Salad,
right?
You got a giant salad,
but the protein somewhere in your fucking day,
lunch and dinner.
Why don't you do that right up until thanksgiving,
you know,
and right through the Thanksgiving weekend.
Why don't you just do that every day?
So I'm gonna get on that fucking motherfucking elliptical and knock out a half
hour.
Why don't you do that?
Instead of eating yourself into a food coma and then you're going to have all
that sugar is sugar and salt in you and you know what you're going to be
thinking,
I should work out and all that fucking stuff is going to be sitting on your
brain goes,
no,
ain't no working out.
He's Ho shit near become enough fat.
Fuck is easy.
Yes it is easy.
Anything worth anything where something in life,
it's difficult.
Um,
come on guys.
What are we doing here?
Huh?
Aren't we fat enough?
How much longer,
uh,
America,
are we going to sit here and gloat?
How much poison is food?
We have more poisonous food than any other nation on the planet.
You know,
how much longer?
It's not even really point.
I think most of it now that I'm starting to watch these things on nutrition is
how they just had the whole thing upside down in the whole food pyramid was
created by a guy who didn't know shit about food,
who went to fucking Italy post World War Two where they lost through a bunch of
God damn nerds.
Italy lost that.
They lined up with fucking a star over there,
right?
Adolf Hitler.
Right.
They lined up with him and they lost.
So he went over to a fucking war torn country,
postwar,
right?
Everybody was fucking broke.
So everyone was skinny and he equated it to their fucking diet and started
talking about how you wanted to do a bunch of carbohydrates.
Like these fucking guys who lost a Goddamn war.
Not Tell you something like that.
I Dunno,
I'll post a video.
Um,
but all I know is like,
y'all know that stuff is like the devil.
I still cannot get my head around the fact that I can eat this much meat into,
I still don't.
I think,
you know,
I guess it's my mother always said everything in moderation is she would yell
across the room.
Right.
Um,
so I guess that's what you want to do.
So I'm,
I'm just going to,
I'm going to do what the fuck I always do.
I do a ton of God damn cardio and I stopped beating around five o'clock,
six o'clock and then I just crushed the waters.
One of the meals is a fucking salad.
That's what I do.
All right.
That's how I lose weight.
I don't sit around blaming society or the fucking industry I'm in,
right is I'm eating a fucking candy Dapple,
like a lot of these fucking people out there
that it just give it in to their sugar,
salt coma and then want you to sit there and accept their defeat rather than
standing up and giving them a halftime fucking speech,
you know,
grabbing him by the back of their hair and pulling it out of that bowl of
fucking painted and fucking chocolate m and m's and get right in that grill.
Like Bobby Knight used to poking him in the chest,
you know,
talking to them about their transition game between one meal to another.
Yeah.
That's what's happening out there,
right?
This Co,
this fucking countries getting,
it's getting soft.
It's getting soft.
Everybody's a Goddamn fucking victim.
Everybody has a fucking excuse,
right?
And everybody's letting them get away with it going like now.
Now,
now,
now.
All right.
It's not the potato chips fault.
Your fault.
All right?
You control your hands.
Stop telling your hands to go into the bag.
All right?
If you wait a head of lettuce to what you eat,
those fucking chips,
like I'm telling you right now,
you'd be a goddamn drink boat.
You know what you got to do?
Quit your fucking crying.
All right,
I'm done.
You know what song is in my head when I want to?
I was just talking to,
I'm in the middle of a radio tour right now promoting my dates in,
uh,
Albuquerque and an Arizona.
I didn't know where the hell I'm going to be in Arizona.
Tucson or some shit.
And then I got a Hollywood,
Florida and I have Orlando,
Florida.
Well,
I will be going to the Orlando Magic game.
The last team I need to see protein that I need to see in the state of Florida.
Plus I've seen the Miami hurricanes and the Florida gators.
What's left?
You ask the Florida State Seminoles.
Yeah.
You know,
and his central Florida keeps making noise.
I got,
I got to go down there eventually.
Right?
Uh,
I dunno.
I guess what's left is to fucking tried to Swim Lake Okeechobee,
whatever the hell it is and try not to get eaten by an alligator and maybe the
python that ate the fucking alligator.
I don't,
I don't pretend to understand these things.
I don't try to pretend to understand what Florida is.
MMM.
Well,
whatever.
I was just in the middle of this radio tour and I was joking around with fucking
guy that was interviewing me and somehow we started singing that song.
Brandy,
remember that sound brandy was a fucking bitch.
He ain't dead two and hippos see it.
But he said they're hidden,
non up pirate and he never would commit to her.
It's such a sad song when you really listen to the fucking lyrics.
It's like she sounds like such a nice woman.
Why doesn't she get out of that fucking bar and stopped talking to those,
those,
those whalers,
whatever the hell she's talking to,
their job takes him out to sea.
I did one cruise ship and my entire career,
I have never been further away from anything that I knew or loved in my life.
You know,
people go on cruises to get rid of their spouse,
you know when they went through with the marriage that they didn't want to be
in.
And rather than just looking at everybody just saying,
I don't want to do this and just let everybody pelt you with the wedding cake.
Next thing you know your lane and your little fucking cabin on a cruise ship
going like,
all right,
so
I'll tell it.
I'm going to take a picture of our mouth.
Oh my God.
I just,
the shit that people do,
it happens to guys too.
People fall overboard in those things.
Why am I talking about cruise ships?
I don't even know why.
Oh yeah.
So why would this woman commit to these fucking people?
Okay.
You know,
they always make it out like she's the victim.
I think what really happened was I think brandy didn't want a relationship.
You know,
maybe that's what it was.
I just feel like for me,
all right,
so I'm 91 days into not drinking.
I'm in overtime right now.
The movie is wrapped,
a basically done with my gigs for the sheer,
I'm chilling out.
I'm getting into the holiday spirit or Billy,
the baker's going to rear its ugly head.
I think I'm gonna make a blueberry pie this year.
You know I'm going to deep fry a fucking Turkey,
but my wife won't let me buy the apparatus.
Why can't we just order one?
I Dunno,
cause it's not as fun is not that sense of satisfaction knowing that somebody
else made the fucking Turkey.
What kind of man of mine?
I'm going to have somebody else cooked my fucking Turkey.
I mean it doesn't that sound borderline filthy.
That's like something.
If you whispered it in a woman's here at work,
I mean you'd have a fucking problem.
Harry.
Deep Fry my Turkey for me.
The fuck did you just say to me?
All right.
Um,
I dunno,
but you know,
I'm getting to this point that I'm starting to understand
like there's this weird balance you have to have when you're married.
You have to say exactly what the fuck you thinking.
You have to be honest with your partner while totally agreeing with everything
that they say.
I haven't figured it out yet.
You know?
Hey,
meets the Francico to Brunch.
Do you want to go?
No.
No,
I don't.
Why?
Because it's always crowded.
It's always crowded.
You go down there,
you got to stand there.
Then you're standing outside waiting for them to fucking call your name and then
when they finally call your name,
he's sitting there eating has all these other people are eyeballing your plate,
breathing down your fucking neck from across the room.
Okay.
It's like the food version of playing golf.
Is there anything worse than playing golf and you've got that fucking do you got
those?
Goddamn borderline pros.
A plane right behind Ya and you just see them just fucking like 80 yards away.
Like throwing their hands up like Jesus Christ.
How many fucking attempts do you need?
It's that same kind of pressure.
It's just like fucking play through.
Eat through buddy.
You want to sit down and order?
I'll fucking pick my plate up.
I don't know.
Somewhere in now.
I being honest with my wife
Roger.
Yeah.
Don't you like me anymore?
It's like lady,
I married you.
Okay.
I'm paying all the bills.
What more?
This whole thing crumbles over some fucking eggs and I don't want to go down and
get,
we got eggs in the fridge sweetheart.
Why don't you bring your friends over here?
They'll sit out on the back porch cause you want to get dressed up.
We want to go out and look cute and have other women resent us for how cute we
are talking about his pitches off of there being cute and so fucking mad at
them.
Okay.
All right,
so now that I'm back,
I ordered the NHL and the NBA package as of yesterday,
I watched my first NHL game.
Why it a why yesterday,
Bruins verse the Anaheim ducks in a few was rooting for the Bruins.
What are fucking sticker?
I know we're really bagged up in that type of thing,
but Jesus Christ,
the one problem the Boston Bruins have had ever since they decided to blow up
the team is we lack that fucking power forward.
That person that is on the ice that everybody else has to be like,
Oh fuck,
keep your head on a Goddamn swivels.
So and so's out there.
Every team,
if you want to compete in the NHL,
you gotta have that.
It's like a fucking great white shark just swimming around.
Everybody's just hoping that thing just got done eating.
You know what I mean?
And you always keeping an eye out.
Where the fuck is that thing?
You know?
It was great white sharks.
They just,
they just swim.
So God damn slowly until pow,
they fucking turn it on.
Next thing you know,
you got to fucking 90 rows of teeth coming at you,
right?
Okay.
You're all drunk swimming naked out to a boy or whatever the fuck it is you're
doing at the beginning of jaws.
We don't have that ever since we got rid of Lou Cheech and uh,
I don't think that those people come and go out on a limb and say those guys are
very few and far between.
We got to have our guy,
um,
who's our enforcer,
I don't even know.
And I looked at the Celtics roster as I mentioned.
It's like I knew every,
everybody on the Celtics and now I know like three of them,
they got rid of everybody,
but I heard they're playing great and I believe they have a game tonight.
So I'm going to watch that.
And I also want to say the Bruins and playing back to back down here.
I think they're playing the kings.
These are always brutal games.
Bruins always come out here and fucking loose.
I can't believe the kinks it took him so God damn long to win this many games
all these years.
Everybody comes down here and wants to just party in Hollywood and try to fuck a
movie star.
That's what everybody's doing,
right?
So then they come to the game all hung over,
right.
Smelling like the flavor of the month,
whoever the fuck they just bagged.
And then they go in there and they just walked through the game and they get
their fucking asses kicked it.
This is what happens every God damn time.
But at least you can go down to Anaheim and beat the ducks.
Right?
The,
the,
these equally injured ducks.
But we couldn't get it done.
We couldn't get fact that ducks have won the last eight regular season games
against the Bruins.
They fucking owners,
uh,
t were an original six team getting owned by a team that's made after a Disney
kid movie.
How fucking sad as a,
I have no idea.
So anyways,
uh,
okay.
I am just going to keep going with the streak.
I'm not,
I'm,
I'm going to get to at least a hundred days and then see how I feel.
But if I go through the end of the year,
I'll have four solid months that I didn't drink.
So that's like a third of the year,
which for most people would be good.
But if you saw the level with which I abused alcohol,
just slapping it all over,
all over the room,
uh,
I would feel better if that number was up around six.
But,
uh,
as I've mentioned,
I'm turning 50 next year and I'm going to be fucking,
I'm going staying in my fifties.
I'm going to try to,
anyways,
I might regret telling you guys that I'm doing that,
but I'm telling you if I,
if I can ever get fucking healthy,
I got another injury.
All right?
Listen to this.
I did inside the NFL,
which you could watch this week on showtime,
right?
And,
um,
okay,
I'm doing the show.
I'm having a great time.
Oh,
you know,
it was fucking hilarious.
I was in the green room and I walk in and,
uh,
Ray Lewis is there and I start telling them how I scalped a ticket to go to a
ravens game.
Okay.
I've told this story before.
I scalped a ticket and I go in and I sit down,
I'm like,
Holy Shit,
this is,
I could like announce the game from where I'm sitting.
And I'm like,
this is the one of the best scalped tickets.
I have a gun for a great price.
And all of a sudden the security guy just goes,
excuse me sir.
Uh,
I've been sad for about half hour.
is that your seat?
Do you have to take for the Eggo a yeah,
yeah,
it is.
And he goes,
oh great.
Could,
could you come out to the Ao for a second?
So I came,
I looked at my ticket.
He goes,
yeah,
that is,
you're a,
that is your seat.
Um,
where did you get this ticket?
And I was like,
hey,
scalped it outside.
He goes,
okay,
I understand.
Oh,
can you just come down the stairs for a second?
So I come down the stairs now there's another security personnel.
There's two security people are,
can you describe the person that you bought this ticket off of?
I'm like,
I don't know.
He had a shirt.
I know it's going to go.
Ah,
no,
it's just,
we just have some questions.
Can you walk down this aisle?
Peanut come like underneath.
So now we're underneath the thing and I find just say to the guy,
go look,
can you quit kicking me out of this stadium 10 feet at a time?
What's going on here?
And then the guy goes,
well these were stolen.
Um,
these are season tickets and they were stolen out of one of our season ticket
holders,
mailboxes.
So,
um,
this is his stolen ticket.
I go,
oh,
so what's some schooling and go,
no,
no.
Well we're going to try to see if,
uh,
you know,
we can get you another ticket,
blah,
and they will get me all the way downstairs.
Now I'm right next to the,
to like the side door.
And I go,
can you give me another ticket?
They're like,
yeah,
unfortunately not.
And then they just kicked me out.
The whole thing was they didn't want me to flip out and scream and yell.
And for everybody,
the fucking NFL,
it's just,
there's such [inaudible],
God forbid there's an issue,
right?
So I'm telling the guys there the story,
they're all laughing.
So I went out and I scalped.
I actually was so mad that I was getting kicked out that I said the fucking
scalper was a tall,
skinny white dude who was actually a short black guy.
And I don't even know why I did that.
I was just so fucking mad.
I didn't want to help anybody out.
So I went back outside scalped another ticket.
I paid even more money.
Now I'm sitting in the lower deck and I said,
yeah,
and I go that.
And they're all laughing,
listen to the story and go,
yeah,
that's the game that it was against Cleveland.
That was the game with that dude on the browns ran for like 300 yards and set
the rushing record and all of a sudden ray Lewis just,
he dropped his head a little bit and he just starts staring at me and I'm
laughing.
I'm going.
So man,
that go put up like 295 yards because what are you talking about?
I got Denny Denny run and then he goes,
then he goes,
no,
he goes,
that was our guy.
I forget.
He said the guy's name.
He goes,
he ran for like two 95.
And I said,
Oh,
I'm sorry,
my bad that I laugh.
I go,
Jesus Christ,
dude,
you are fucking looking at me.
You went all full metal jacket.
And everyone just started laughing.
Do Ray Lewis is like the fucking coolest guy ever.
And he's still like,
if you saw how like hurt he was,
that I would ever suggest that anyone put up close to 295 yards on a Raven's
defense that he was a part of.
Um,
I got to ask all those guys so many cool questions.
I actually,
uh,
I asked Ray Lewis if he had a,
you know,
what's it like being one of the great linebackers of all time watching how these
linebackers,
you know,
get to just sort of,
I mean,
it's the wide receivers just to kind of get to skip down the damn field now.
And he goes,
oh,
he goes,
I can't,
I have a hard time watching.
And he goes,
I got to take like blood pressure medicine.
I'm like walking around watching the game.
So anyways,
we're uh,
we're in between segments and they actually did this segment on like how the
guys on defense don't know what they can and can't get away with.
So they're playing timid and these wide receivers and quarterbacks and running
back.
So having a field day out there.
So of course boomer Esiason is siding with the offense and um,
everyone on the show was signed with dietetic overpoliced a blah,
blah,
blah.
So anyway,
so the segment ends and boomers continue with the conversation.
He goes,
did you see what happened to Aaron Rodgers?
And he goes to,
the guy came over and he pay him.
Boomer walks over and he goes to pick me up.
And I don't know why I should've said boomer,
I saw the play.
So he goes to pick me up.
You know,
when you go to pick somebody up,
what you do is you pull them in towards you and you put the pressure of you
lifting them up across their back.
He didn't,
he tried to pick me up from my sides and like crushed my rib cage and you just
hear it.
I just heard you just heard something pop on my right side.
And he goes,
Oh shit.
They put me down and he and I got,
I dunno why just go.
I think that was my back and he goes,
really?
It sounded like your ribs.
And I knew instantly that he fucked me up.
He,
I don't know what the fuck he did to my obliques.
It's not like some lifelong shit,
you know what I mean?
I'm not a millennial.
I'm not going to sue anybody.
This is just like four days.
Epson salt bath.
But like I knew immediately fucked me up and if somehow somebody sends this to
him,
I want him to know that when I sit here it doesn't hurt.
But I drove my car down at,
uh,
in alley yesterday trying to like beat this traffic and it had all these
potholes select.
The suspension was rocking back and forth.
So I was going side to side and I had to use my old bleaks.
I was just going down the alley.
Ah,
ah,
but I'm good cause I can laugh right now.
It still feels fine.
But uh,
yeah,
you know,
it would have been such a cooler story if it was Ray Lee,
Ray Lewis who did it to me as opposed to a quarterback.
But here's the deal.
He's still like six,
four and all of those guys have like fucking gorilla strength and I'm just a
comedian and my baby blue sweater.
Um,
anyway,
so how funny is that?
I actually went on a fucking football program with ex NFL players and came out
of there with an injury.
I'm like day to day right now.
I would still start on Sunday if we were playing football,
they'd spray it with something.
Um,
but anyways,
I had such a great time with all of those guys and uh,
Ray Lewis,
Nate and a boomer,
I had such a great time on that whole thing.
And of course J B,
we were all teasing him about his haircut.
I don't know if it made it,
but I said he looked like count Basie and they were trashing me for being bald.
And all of that.
It was just a,
I wish I lived in New York.
That's how much fun I had on that show.
Um,
but also I also realize like how little football I watched when I was on there,
like when I had to pick the teams,
like I had no idea what anybody's doing.
You know,
my daughter's crawling,
she starting to stand up at this point.
I mean that alone,
I can barely pay attention and was in the writer's room and then immediately
went down to the acting gig.
So,
uh,
my apology,
I mean,
of all the fucking years for me to get back on that show,
the one year,
I think next year I'm going to get to watch a lot more.
But,
uh,
I was sitting there like the Foi and went on the show,
like trying to study up,
like,
you know,
the day before you finally,
and you know,
you're not going to pass,
but you just try to get a respectable flunking grade.
And,
uh,
you know,
even after all that studying,
I have no idea who the fuck is gonna win it.
I know the eagles and the rams are doing well.
It has other Vikings and,
uh,
and even though the Patriots is seven and two,
I never believe in our defense.
I just don't think we get enough pressure on the fucking quarterback.
And A,
they seem to be able to do pretty well against our secondary this year.
So we'll see.
I don't know.
But anyways,
thank you to everybody over there for having me on inside the NFL.
Please,
uh,
watch it.
This week,
uh,
Nate gave me shit about deflate gate and I of course,
took the bait once again.
I always take the bait.
I should've just been like,
hey man,
you know,
fucking,
I got five reasons to not get upset holding up all five fingers for the five
rings we got.
And I never thought to do that.
I immediately,
um,
so anyway,
so I did the fucking show and then immediately I went down to a,
I went right to the airport because I wanted to see,
uh,
get onto my fam,
my family over and my family bank west out west.
You go back east and you go out west and uh,
I get to Newark Airport and I'm hungry and I quickly realized there's no way to
get food in the air.
I flew United in the entire fucking terminal.
When you showed up,
wherever you went to sit down to eat,
if there's any sort of sit down and eating,
you had to be your own waiter.
You had to interact with this fucking iPad.
And the second I sit down,
I'm looking at my face on the screen.
I'm like,
what the fuck is this?
So I cover the camera with my wallet and the lady comes over,
I do Nada you.
Then I'm like,
I'm not a waiter sweetheart.
I don't work at this restaurant.
Why am I being,
why don't I,
you know,
I was being a dick to her and everything.
Um,
in the end I tipped her in cash.
So I did.
I said,
listen,
I'm not upset with you.
I'm just upset with his fucking apparatus here.
I like human beings.
Okay.
And I don't like this thing,
you know,
filming me here,
cause that's not filming you.
It's just going to take a picture.
You get ticket.
It's like,
what the fuck does Wendy's give a fuck about what airline?
I'm flying on you gathering information and had to sit there and act like this
thing isn't filming me.
They're going to be like white male looks to be about this old ordered the fried
chicken sandwich and they're gonna use,
just take it.
They're just constantly sucking this fucking information out about you.
So I'm just sit down,
don't scan your fucking ticket.
Um,
they're going to use all that information like,
oh no,
we're just trying to,
you know,
if it's getting too close in your,
your,
your plane is boarding and blah,
blah,
blah.
They're not,
that's what they're doing on one side.
But on the other side that figuring out what race,
what sex,
what you ordered,
where you live,
how you dressed,
all of this fucking information so you can get bombarded with even more fucking,
uh,
you know,
I dunno,
even more advertising.
However,
if you just committed a murder and you think that you know by them filming you
there and that's a good alibi,
then bought by all means don't cover it.
But,
um,
I don't know if the whole thing is fucking annoying to me.
And next time I go to Newark Airport,
I'm just going to make sure I eat before I get there because this guy,
oh frack,
this freckled con,
he ain't playing ball.
All right.
And with that,
let me read some advertising before the next person calls me here.
Um,
ah,
look who it is,
but up,
up,
up me,
Andy's Mian days.
Stop taking my picture on an iPad.
But Dude,
dude,
me undies,
I'm not happy.
I'm fucking mad.
Why am I working for your fucking joint?
A who gives a fuck?
I don't know.
I don't even fucking know.
I,
I'm sorry.
I just tapped out of that thing.
And lately I've just been picking words that don't even,
I can't rhyme them joint.
I know fucking work here.
That's my point.
Bring a lady out here to take my order and explain what the fuck I'm doing.
I'm not a millennial.
No,
you can't have my social security number.
All right,
me undies,
everybody beyond his.
Let me tell you about me undies.
The only underwear that makes for an amazing gift Biondi is soft,
flexible,
like the horror up the street,
and three to three times softer than cotton me undies makes the perfect gift.
You know what?
They should come out with a horse.
Muzzle underwear.
You know what I mean?
Soft as a horse.
Muzzle muzzle up against your privates.
Me undies makes the perfect gift.
It's the God damn holidays this year.
Don't give underwear.
Give me undies.
Uh,
this holiday season to get your exclusive 20% off the softest underwear and
socks you'll ever wear.
Free Shipping and 100% satisfaction guarantee.
Go to [inaudible] dot com slash bird that's me,
undies.com/burn all we look at this.
We only have one more left.
We only got one more left.
Southie.
Everybody,
me,
Yow,
everyone at some point has wished they could just have a beer,
wine or liquor delivered.
Well,
someone finally decided to do something about,
well,
why stop there?
Why not bring some cocaine,
some weed.
Introducing Southie.
Me How,
uh,
the alcohol delivery APP saucy or delivers your favorite wine,
beer and liquor,
right to you.
Do a on demand.
It's Uber for alcohol.
Did you wake up face down,
still wearing the clothes from last night and have too big a headache,
but you can still reach for the phone and you want a little hair of the dog.
Saucy is the APP for you.
Now,
if you're in Los Angeles,
San Francisco,
Chicago,
San Diego or Sacramento,
you're saucy order will arrive at your door in 30 minutes or less.
Ready to drink for the rest of us.
Saucy.
We'll deliver beer,
wine and liquor.
Uh,
yeah.
Wine in Lik Quarto your door.
I don't know what the fuck copy this is in two days or less nationwide.
Hey guys,
get your Thanksgiving order and now there are no premiums,
no delivery fees,
no running to the store.
If you got the saucy APP,
you've got a fully stocked bar on your phone and for a limited time you can get
$15 off when you download this saucy app and enter Promo Code Bar.
That's the saucy APP,
spelled s,
u,
c e y.
And enter Promo Code Burr for $15 off.
Get the saucy app today.
Use Promo Code [inaudible].
All right.
Ah,
AH,
fuck.
There you go.
See that?
I had to sit up and I was on my side.
Um,
oh fuck.
I already got a missed call.
Okay.
I gotta get back to this radio tour.
All right.
That's,
that's the Thursday afternoon.
Just checking in on all that was some 30 minutes ago.
I think I'm good.
I'm just checking in on your fucking podcast here.
Uh,
what else?
I got another two minutes here,
don't I?
I've got another two minutes,
unless somebody fucking calls me here.
Uh,
what else?
What else is there to talk about?
Oh,
I'm going to go to my little studio space and play my drums today for the first
time.
And like,
I think like three weeks can to see if I remember how to do it,
but I've been hitting the practice pad pretty hard.
Um,
get back to taking some lessons.
I'm going to be that fucking guy and this is what I want.
This one I'm gonna be able to do on drums.
All right?
If I hear it,
I want to be able to play it.
And then my technique,
I want to not even have to think about it and have my forearms.
Everything's Nice and relaxed.
Relax,
sitting up straight.
Just one of those fucking guys.
And then I can actually see,
you know,
if I actually have any sort of talent for the goddamn instrument,
that is my goal in 2018.
All right.
And that's it.
Okay.
Somebody's going to be calling me any second here and I'm gonna have to promote
one of my gigs.
Uh Oh,
I know what I gotta tell you.
I'm doing a Gig for Puerto Rico Ho.
I'm doing a Gig for Puerto Rico the Monday before Thanksgiving at the laugh
factory down in Long Beach.
Okay.
This is a very important gig because what happened out there was devastated and
our president just brought paper towels.
That's all that happened.
Let me see if I can get you this information here.
Where is my,
where is my account?
I haven't tweeted that much.
Shafai profile.
I go to the profile.
I scroll down,
it won't let me of course tweets.
How do I find out a click on my picture?
I slide over.
Okay,
here we go.
Scrolling down,
scrolling down.
Where's the shit that I tweeted?
I Dunno.
I'll get you all the information as far as,
no wait,
I'll look up.
I'll look up current shit here.
Hang on one second.
Hang on.
Hang on,
hang on.
I just fucking relax.
All right,
here we go.
All right.
No,
Monday,
November 20th.
Hey,
look who's here?
What's up buddy?
Please don't touch my laptop.
How you doing?
Monday,
November 20th,
I'm doing a benefit for the people of Puerto Rico.
Uh,
all the information will be on my website.
And here's the next phone call.
All right.
I was looking at my daughter and almost said to you guys,
I love you guys to death.
No,
I need to say,
do you guys go f yourself?
So I love my daughter.
Did that look at Geo Acuity?
All right,
go enjoy the music.
I'll check in on you on Thursday.
All the sisters.
Oh,
cool.
Wow.
Well done.
The
odd [inaudible]
good man.
Eat you.
Hey,
what's going on?
It's Belper and it is a Monday morning podcast for Monday,
November 16th,
2009 and uh,
I'm actually recording this set a 12 noon on a Sunday.
What do you think about that?
How do you like that for forward fucking thinking?
You liked that?
I anticipated that Monday was coming on Sunday and I got the fucking thing out
of the way.
So right now you're listening to it and your little cubicle.
Oh my God.
He actually got it done on time.
I just so exciting.
If fucking hate my job,
it's fucking nine in the morning.
My boss is a current and I get to listen to this and act like I'm looking at
spreadsheets.
They you go,
I finally did it every once in a while that come through for the people on the
east coast and a,
you might be asking yourself,
why bill,
why were you so motivated?
I'll tell you why.
Because for some fucking reason I have been,
I've been,
I've been going to sleep like a little old lady this week.
You know,
you have it just to get in one of those weird sleep patterns where raw right
after the evening news,
you know,
you watch a little bit of jeopardy,
you slip off your loafers.
So you sit there on the Davenport trying to think of some fucking old people
terms here.
I Dunno.
And I've been going to bed like at nine 30,
10 and then I've been getting up at six in the morning like a farmer,
you know,
like a farmer.
I just said that cause I know this farmers out there will probably listen to
this.
Julie would get up at four in the morning.
You refocus really
good for you.
What time do you go to bed?
You know,
they're all fucking works out,
doesn't it?
I'm speaking of farmers actually saw a food inc this week because some a podcast
listener.
I wanted to say that real close podcast listener,
a recommended it.
And uh,
the classic give and take care of the Monday morning podcast.
I learned a little thing.
You little learn a little thing.
I say,
fuck you.
Everybody laughs.
Um,
somebody told me to rent that,
that a documentary food inc.
And let me tell you,
it was very,
very interesting,
very interesting to see where the food comes from and uh,
what exactly goes on to the food before the food gets to my table.
And A,
which is why this morning I want,
I got up so early to go to a farmer's market.
I wanted to go where the a with the local guys make it,
you know,
where they let the chickens run free before they murdered them.
This is a free range chicken.
It had up fucking wonderful seven weeks on this planet before we stuck it in a
funnel and sliced it.
Throat actually had video of how they kill the chickens.
That's what they stick them in.
These little,
uh,
the,
the down home farmers.
The regular old farmer wasn't given into the man dude.
Um,
they got like a,
you ever see like those fancy Baker's right as opposed to the blue collar bakers
who got those fat little thumbs.
Um,
the fancy Baker's when they go to make one of those,
those uh,
cakes for some fancy fucking douche bag who's probably a slum Lord,
right?
You know,
when they go to put the frosting on,
you know,
that little fucking reverse trumpet thing that they use.
Why am I going so far?
Look at,
do you remember if you have a seat back in the day,
the original football games when they're like,
Rah Rah sis,
boom bye bye man.
They were yelling through that little fucking,
that little fucking funnel thing.
It had a handle on it.
I know.
You guys know what I'm talking about where they have those and they have like
the part,
you know the part where you're yelling too that's on that would be like,
ah,
Jesus.
How can I explain this picture?
If you had one of those Rah Rah sis,
boom Bah things,
right,
and you wanted to yell up to the heavens and you fucking cocky and neck back and
the thing was going straight up.
That's the way they have these things.
And they have them in a circle,
like,
like 10 silver ones,
and they take these chickens and they'll low ball and they fucking stick them in
head first.
So they go right down the fucking funnel and then a little chicken heads
sticking out the bottom and they're like all,
and then they fucking sliced her throat and they bleed them out.
That's how they do it on the regular old farms.
That's how they do it.
And uh,
the other ones more industrial once,
they don't quite do it that way.
So Watch how food INC check it out.
Um,
you know,
at the end it's a bunch of fucking dead animals.
But,
uh,
I dunno,
I like clean food.
Call me crazy.
But I liked clean food so many ways.
I was supposed to get up,
you know,
early this morning,
I've been all excited all this week cause you know me,
I see one little thing that says a corporation is fucking me over.
And then that becomes my quest for that week.
You know,
it's why I don't talk on my cell phone anymore.
It's why I don't trust banks.
It's why I'm not a Democrat or Republican.
It all comes down to some fucking video that some fat fuck living in his
mother's basement has made.
And I just take it as law.
That's how I do it.
Okay.
And um,
okay.
So the whole week I've been obsessed with going to the fucking farmer's market
and every day I'm going to go and we're going,
right,
we're going.
And finally yesterday my girl couldn't take anymore and she's just like,
yes,
we're going,
you know when they get that,
okay,
they get like that fucking uh,
tone in their voice.
And I was just like,
what a Douche was.
My immediate thought,
I just turned around and walked out because uh,
you can't slap them even though they deserve it sometimes.
At least he could throw something at us,
you know,
something that's in between nerf in a blunt object.
What would that be?
You know,
beyond a pillow but not quite the refrigerator door.
How about a soft covered book isn't that,
and you know,
Frisbee it Adam,
cause that might catch the corner and their eye.
What you do is you sort of lob it at him,
you know,
like a Robert Parish foul shot half that,
not the rain ball.
Sort of like a half rainbow,
you know,
and it just lands on them.
The fucking meaty part of their thigh makes that nice slap sound.
Um,
anyways.
Yeah.
So she annoys the shit out of me.
Right?
Well again at got,
okay.
Typical broad acting like I'm being a fucking Douche bag.
Right.
And what happens this morning?
Yeah,
she's fucking sleep and like boxcar Willie until like 11 in the morning.
And she clearly told me like fucking months ago that you have to get over there
early because if you don't get over there early enough,
there's just gonna be a bunch of strawberries laying on the sidewalk,
you know?
So she finally gets up,
right?
She finally gets up around,
she's in the other room,
so you have to whisper here.
She finally gets up around fucking 11
and I'm all sleepy eye and she's like,
ah.
And she knows she fucked up.
Okay.
She knows it.
I know it.
The downstairs neighbor knows it.
Everybody knows she's fucked up.
Why did she fuck up?
Because she overslept now.
She fucked up cause she was a Douche the day before acting like I was
overreacting like that worry,
we're going to fucking go.
And what does she do?
She goes out,
she has a couple of pops and next thing you know she sleeps till fucking 11 all
right.
And you're probably like,
well bill,
why didn't you go in their wake?
Wake her up.
Oh,
I'll tell you why.
Because she's been breaking my balls about how I keep going to bed at nine 30
and then I start puttering around like some war veteran at five in the morning,
this whole fucking week.
So I let her sleep thinking maybe she get up at night and maybe she get up at
nine 30 maybe 10 at 10 I just said,
you know what?
Who gives a fuck?
I've been eaten corn fed beef for the law my whole fucking life.
You know,
I'm still walking around.
I'll do it for week.
Who gives a shit?
Right.
Since she wakes up 11 she's a haystack.
Okay.
God,
he fell.
Getting out of the fire is bad again.
I was like,
no,
no we're not.
She's like,
well I know I go cause you told me all this shit was uh,
is gone if you don't get there early,
so why do I want to go over there now?
I also like going over there earlier because I'm a red head and we live in a
desert and I don't feel like standing out in the middle of the fucking street at
11 o'clock in the morning.
Plus the football games are already on.
So then what does she do?
You know,
the typical codependence shit.
She keeps trying to get me to go with her.
Well there's still gonna be some stuff left.
They'll have Kale.
They'll health from Broccoli.
Yeah.
I don't give a shit.
I was going over there for the meat.
That's what,
that's what I was doing.
So you can't come with me.
No,
I still like her come with me.
That fucking nightmare and I just refuse to fucking go.
I'd gotten on with my day.
I started paying my bills for Monday.
I was going to do the podcast,
I'm going to go fucking work out.
And of course the second I started this podcast,
who comes walking in the door,
my girl comes walking in and informed me that there was still plenty of shit
left,
which is still not my fault.
I went by her information that nothing would be left and for all I know she's
fucking lion.
You know,
there was plenty of stuff left.
He could have come with me,
Athol.
Um,
so that's been my fucking morning.
and I also realized that my fucking patriots don't play until eight o'clock at
night,
which is five o'clock out here at five 30.
So,
so I had nothing better to do.
I decided I'd do a fucking podcast rather than sitting here doing nothing when
she came home because then she could have been like,
well,
why didn't she come with me?
Um,
anyways,
uh,
let's,
this is the Monday morning podcast.
Does any of that make any fucking sense?
What does that just a classic boring fucking relationship story?
Did I just bore you for fucking nine minutes and 33 seconds?
Well,
I hope you,
I hope I did because I've been getting too many complaints about the fucking
podcast lately.
I liked it back in the day you were more angrier,
Bill,
do it on your cell phone again.
You know whoever's wrote me that,
you know,
what did you use to do?
Why don't you go do that?
Why don't you stop evolving as a fucking human being and just do it the way you
did it two years ago where the same fucking shirt.
You know what I mean?
You want it the exact same way.
Every fucking a fucking idiots.
Dude.
I like their new stuff.
I liked their first two albums.
I don't like the,
I don't like when they changed and I should like people were into bands like
that,
like people who were into like fucking youtube,
you know,
people just can't fucking respect for the fact that they've continued to fucking
evolve and put out killer songs,
changed their sound,
come back to their sound,
divert from it.
Become huge.
Rock stars mock being huge.
Rock stars always coming up with new way to make it a little bit different.
There always has to be that fucking douchebag going.
I liked it back.
I only liked him.
I liked him up until war or boy or whatever the name of their fucking albums
are.
I don't even remember.
I remember that one that had that fucking creepy looking kid,
you know,
looks like the poster for the grudge like 20 years before it fucking came out.
Like there's always people like that.
Okay.
Granted there are bands that evolved and then they suck like Jefferson airplane
when they became Jefferson Star ship.
But I,
I challenge you to find anything in the youtube catalog that comes anywhere near
sucking to the level of,
we built this city on rock and roll.
Yeah.
That is one of the worst.
Okay.
Everything,
you know that they like when they show some of the worst dictators and I'm
really trying to avoid to say Adolph Hitler because he becomes,
he's become like the hacky reference when you talk about evil,
you know,
and I really think that that guy is a,
and a lot of ways overrated when you look at is number of kills verse Stalin's.
Okay.
I've talked about this before.
Stalin has 20 million confirmed kills.
Okay.
That's fucking like what?
14 million more.
14 million more than Hitler and about fucking 19 million.
900,000
more than fucking ramble.
Okay.
Um,
I'm,
you know what,
I'm [inaudible] that's my,
that's my thing.
That's what that's going to be my contribution to conversation in fucking dinner
parties.
You know,
I'm going to start going to those,
by the way,
I'm going to get a smoking jacket and all that.
And when people go like,
oh my God,
he's like the next Hitler and I mean,
now he's the next styling.
Who is that?
I don't know who the fuck that.
Of course you don't get dumped.
Fuck.
You probably know that.
You know what Hitler did do ya?
Or You just and fucking spout in the shit out the way.
I do every week on the podcast.
You dumb fuck I'm speaking of which this is,
this is a new part of the podcast.
It's,
it's this,
the bills,
dumb bells,
dumb quote of the week.
Um,
I had a bunch of people,
um,
correct me on something that I've been saying for years.
I use the expression,
I said for all extensive purposes and somebody wrote for all extensive purposes.
It's not,
um,
you don't say it that way and you don't say it the way most other people say all
intensive purposes.
It's actually for all intense and purposes
you like that.
Most people say for all intensive purposes,
right?
When they fuck it up,
Bill Burr took it to a whole new level of stupid and said for all extensive
purposes.
Yeah.
I do that all the time.
I say there's something else I say it has to do with a,
what the fuck is it?
The beginning of your college year when you're a freshman?
Ah,
Jeez.
And my memory is just fucking shot.
I used to always work those things as a standup comic.
You'd come in,
it'd be like the first,
uh,
why don't I keep thinking salutation?
That's not what it is.
I know it begins with an s though.
Okay.
Oh,
this happens to me like 20 times a day.
Is it some sort of fish that I can be eating to help me with this?
I used to do the gigs every year.
The beginning of the year,
incoming freshmen gigs should come in and they,
we sit in there with their parents and my college age will be like,
uh,
Billy.
Ah,
we got a,
we got,
I got a Gig for,
yeah,
the parents are going to be there.
So it makes it,
you don't say Fuck
God damn.
And I forget,
but whatever I used,
I used to fuck that word up all the time.
Um,
so whatever.
So I learned something.
It's for all intents and purposes,
I used to say Pelo instead of pillow,
p l l,
O,
I'm a fucking moron.
And I don't know why you guys,
you know what?
You assholes.
I know why you listen to me.
You listen to me because my level of stupidity makes you feel better about
yourself,
doesn't it?
Huh?
What does that say about you?
You fucking horse.
See how I got out of that by trying to blame you.
That's,
that's it.
That's a technique I use.
Am I arguing?
Um,
but it hasn't,
wasn't all bad.
I actually got,
I got some thanks last week from a,
from a hormone it said Bill.
Um,
you were wondering if there are any,
oh,
Jesus Christ.
I fucking,
I copied and pasted the wrong one here.
This isn't from a woman.
Listen,
this bill.
Yah.
You were wondering if there were,
there are any Jews that listen to your podcasts.
There are Jews who listened to your podcast.
I am one of them.
And in fact,
an Orthodox Jew.
I'm not Hasidic,
I'm not his Siddiq Jew,
but it's the same thing without the curls.
Dude.
That's bullshit.
There's got to be something more than that.
I know you just made a joke though.
What is the difference between an Orthodox Jew and a Hasidic Jew?
I know.
I could fucking Google that right now and get some other morons.
Fucking not,
I'm not saying you're a moron,
you know what I mean?
Just get some morons version of what that is.
Um,
I wasn't even that place.
I used to go to down on ninth avenue and it was a best electronic store,
uh,
and fucking New York Jr's,
something like that.
It was like a block over from Madison Square Garden at where they are now.
Those guys or those guys,
Orthodox Jews are they Hasidic Jews?
I don't know what they were,
but they were the shit.
They knew about everything and uh,
they had great prices and they weren't open on Sundays and I respected that.
You know,
somebody is still doing it.
The little house in the prairie way observing the sabbath.
Okay.
That's one of the worst things that we've done as a culture as far as getting
away from religion is we got,
we got away from a fucking day off.
You know,
this is how old I am.
I remember when fucking malls and all that shit,
we're closed on Sundays.
You buy liquor.
Is that still true?
Can you still not by luck,
he couldn't buy bear.
You couldn't fucking do anything.
He just had to sit there and think about why God was going to send you to hell,
you know?
But at least you weren't working.
You guys remember that little house in the prairie episode where fucking,
uh,
Michael Landon was busting his ass all week and then they had to go to church on
Sunday and he was so fucking tired.
He fell asleep in his church clothes.
And the mother looked at him and he's like,
should I wake them up?
And she's like,
God,
no,
he's sleeping like an angel.
God wouldn't want me to bring him to church.
He,
he,
he should.
This is a day of rest.
He's resting like the Lord after six days of creating an universe.
So the bitch goes to church,
she goes to church,
and when she comes back,
this asshole woke up from his little slumber and he was outside with an ox and
he was plowing the fields again and all did she get mad at him?
She really got mad at him.
And,
uh,
then the,
that little girl's skipped down the hill and she fell into some shrubs and that
was the end of it.
And that was another episode of Little House on the prairie.
Let's continue on with the a orthodox Jewish person's email.
Cause last week I was talking about a beanie.
Is that,
is that offensive or whatever he said,
I wanted to let you know that there is essentially the Yamaka and yes,
there is an r in there.
Um,
but it's sort of silent is a skull cap as opposed to a beanie,
which you were sort of confused about.
Sort of confused.
You'd be a nice,
here I'm calling it a beanie.
Uh,
should not insult anyone.
It's almost the same thing.
What is the pope were technically,
it's called a,
I can't even read what the is a Catto.
O m also means skullcap.
Um,
the real meaning of the Yamaka is Yar fear of Mecca.
The king and [inaudible] signifies that there is someone up above and that we
are limited moral beings.
Okay.
Well what do you mean it's saying,
okay,
okay.
Doesn't it really signify that there's someone above that you should be scared?
Shit of and that we're limited debts.
Easy.
That's the thing that I never liked about organized religion is the bully
factor.
I couldn't have,
it's just like,
why is this?
How has God already mad at me?
I'm six years old.
You know what I mean?
It just created like if you believe in this higher power,
it's just fucking angry.
Douchebag always looking down at you.
Pissed off at you.
You know what I mean?
Why are you fucking mad at me?
You made me,
you know what I mean?
If I fucking built a car from ground up and it didn't run,
didn't run correctly,
who the fuck am I going to blame the car?
That doesn't make any sense.
Did what I just say make any sense?
I don't fucking know.
I like to just finish this.
Um,
also you mentioned how the guy on the plane was wearing a Yamaka big,
you weren't sure if it was a hat or some sort of giant Yamaka.
I totally agree with you.
I wear a normal size Yamaka and am a little annoyed even when someone wears one
so big that it covers their whole head,
almost like a hat,
but to each his own,
I guess.
Um,
anyways,
a big fan of your comedy and your podcasts.
Uh,
well,
thank you for listening.
I appreciate that.
You don't want to,
I actually have a theory on those big time.
Yamakas I think that that is the,
uh,
that's the poor man's toupee after a while because if you go on bald in the
back,
you start to lose it in the back like I am.
I'm a Yamaka is great because it buys you another three years of people not
knowing that you're losing your hair.
See,
a lot of people don't realize that Sammy Davis Jr was actually losing a little
bit of his Afro and that's why he converted to Judaism.
A lot of people thought it was a,
it was a show business move,
but it wasn't,
he was going bald.
Your hair to,
you heard it here first.
So now I'm fascinated.
What is the difference between an Orthodox Jewish person in his Siddiq shoe?
What is the difference?
And also,
do you believe in an afterlife?
Okay.
Do you believe that God is mad at you?
What are the Catholic Shit that I learned?
Um,
okay.
Can you eat a cheeseburger on Friday?
And I know like all religions,
you consider yourselves 100% right?
And the chosen ones,
you guys have the Notre Dame.
God loves us best.
You know,
do you have that to that disease that is in every fucking religion.
You shouldn't kill anyone,
but God loves us the best said anyone who doesn't believe what we believe,
it's going to hell.
How a great week everybody.
Be sure to pass that on to people who don't believe in.
That's why does every character my fucking act talk like that?
Okay.
What are the priests used to sound like at my church?
Hey,
how you doing?
Look,
I'm pretty good in that old boy outfit.
Go ahead and lift it up a little bit.
Um,
thank you.
That was my impression of a Catholic priest.
All right.
I've been doing a lot of ranting and raving on this podcast.
People,
um,
talking about those little save,
you know,
those little scan cards at the grocery store and somebody told me that what
you're actually doing is taking a survey and a,
you know,
to help them figure out what products you can't live without.
So they can jack the price up and I've actually taken that as law.
So this is somebody and I have had a bunch of different theories.
There's another theory.
Um,
a couple of weeks ago you brought up the saber cards at the store.
I was wondering what the purpose of,
and you are wondering what the purpose of them was.
Um,
you speculated that it was so they knew what you were buying to jack up the
prices.
But with the bar codes,
bar code scanning,
they already know how much inventory they move and what sells better than other
things.
The purpose of the car is to gather your information to sell it to mailing
lists.
Okay.
Who send you junk mail or spam since they always ask for an email address,
they also can be used as an incentive to keep you going to the store instead of
a competitor.
I,
he going to Macy's instead of JC penny's.
Uh,
they give you the discount without the card occasionally.
So you can be lured into saving 10% or so every time you go there.
So they can eventually get your information.
Um,
eh,
your guess is as good as mine.
I don't know what they're up to,
but I also noticed that most of the shit that's on sale is there bootleg version
of the real shit.
You know what I mean?
Like Ralph's olive oil,
you know,
I've noticed that,
uh,
that's another great way.
Like they could be like,
okay,
we're selling the food.
What if we made it also,
you know,
and had our own fucking farms.
I Dunno.
I just don't like,
I don't trust people who are going out of their way to give me a fucking break.
I don't,
you know what I mean?
That's like Dev to fucking Andrew Carnegie kind of like,
yeah,
way of doing shit.
You know,
you fuck people over your whole life and then the Andia life,
you're worried that maybe really there is a god and then you become a
philanthropist and you start giving me your shit away.
Fuck you.
You sit there with your guilt.
I'll pay full price for the peanut butter.
Thank you very much.
All right,
another theory.
Um,
yeah.
Uh,
what the fuck is this one?
This guy says,
I'm a software engineer who finished working for a company that stores and
reports on all sorts of insane sales data.
Some examples of that type of data.
They can gather a sales of products based on ethnicity.
Yeah.
See this is why I think they also want the card because it's not enough to know
all we sold 20 boxes of fruit loops.
They want to know was it a guy,
was it a fucking girl?
How old were they?
What color?
Um,
the main data I saw in this kind was defined as Hispanic or non Hispanic.
I guess that's sales based on ethnicity.
Um,
this is a guy who gathers this data.
I guess he says if there was a floor display in some store,
what is the effect on the sales of the item while it,
the display
what
not worst?
If there was a floor display in the store,
what is the effect on sales of that item while the display is present?
Let's say for example,
there was a NASCAR event spa sponsored by Coca Cola.
They keep track of coke sales in that region.
Around the time of that event.
Furthermore,
they analyze if the cost of sponsoring this event made it,
that made them enough money to profit to make it worthwhile.
Sponsoring similar events.
This is just a small portion of wacky shit.
They update weekly.
That was written in capital letters weekly,
I guess that's important.
Weekly.
Um,
they know every single damn item that was moved out of each and every store
every single week.
So basically the stores with the savvy,
the savvy saved cards get two huge benefits.
They sell this data to my old company to make money and they let the consumer
feel as they got,
they have some kind of superhuman power to save 40 cents when they buy three
gallons of milk in one visit.
So there you
go.
I don't know you're helping them gather information.
I don't like the fucking pricks so I'm not using one.
Um,
all right.
Now let's get to the meat of the podcast here.
People,
shall we,
I'm doing this on a football fucking Sunday right now cause I could give a shit
about other teams in a league right now.
All I give a fuck about right now is my patriots.
And it's basically because I've watched so much fucking hockey this week that
I'm kind of all,
I'm done with sports.
I watched,
I was flipping back and forth between the Ohio state,
Iowa Hawkeyes game this week,
and I was also flipping back between that and the USC Stanford Game and Jesus
Christ.
How about a moment of silence for the fucking fans of the USC Trojans who went
out to sea?
I mean that was a fucking ass rape and you guys took,
you know,
and I'll tell you right now,
Trojan fans,
you have no fucking right getting mad at Jim Harbaugh for going for two point,
let me,
let me set this up.
Basically Stanford was up 48 to 21
for those of you overseas,
usually it just kick an extra point,
right to make it 49 or you can go for a two point conversion.
There's no reason to go for a two point conversion when there's six minutes left
and you're up by four or five scores and they went forward and the crowd started
booing.
And um,
you know,
you got to understand you guys,
USC for the last five years,
you have been raping everyone in the pack.
10 get bent him over.
I mean,
how many times did you guys score a 50,
60 points?
Sent the other team crying on their little team bus,
send them home crying,
right?
Well,
what goes around comes around,
add a,
I became a huge Stanford and Jim Harbaugh fan with the fact that he went for two
points and then he also,
in the end,
they got the ball back again and he went for the end zone.
The end up winning 55 to 21.
Jim Harbaugh was trying to literally end the football program at USC.
It was one of the most venerable act,
the biggest acts of vengeance I've seen in sports in awhile.
I fucking loved every second of it.
Um,
and I was also watching the,
uh,
the Osu,
Iowa Hawkeyes game and those youth fans of the podcast know that my new
tradition is I go to the rose bowl every year.
So both of those games were huge.
I was,
I ain't know,
I really didn't want to see USC again.
Mainly because,
you know,
I like variety.
And that fat cunt from last year's game was a USC fan.
So I'm happy that she had a miserable day and now she probably didn't 100%.
She probably,
you know,
I had a dozen donuts in front of her,
so it wasn't a total loss.
Really.
Bill,
11 months later,
you're still giving a shit about our weight.
Yeah,
I am.
Um,
okay.
And then Iowa,
you know that fucking quarterback for Iowa,
that kid's 19 years old.
I'll tell you all,
you longhorn fans sitting there talking about that Colt Mccoy,
that kid at Ios was,
those are the fucking place.
Those are the passes you have to make to make it onto the fucking pros.
All right?
You have to throw the same kind of throws that they throw at the NFL level.
You can't be running the fucking option and gained in like 150 yards a game.
And then also throwing for 200.
No one gives a fuck the second you start running,
watch Tim Tebow.
Watch that guy.
When he goes into the draft,
that guy's going to be like,
I swear if he goes in the second round,
it's not going to surprise me.
He's a tight end playing fucking you.
You're not in that Jesus Freak.
I don't give a fuck how many psalms he writes underneath his fucking eyes is
going to get laid out and the pro level,
he's going to get fucking laid out.
I guarantee that's my prediction.
All right.
And they're going to make them a flanker.
They're going to bring back that position.
Um,
so anyway,
so I did that.
I watched the,
uh,
and then I watched stuff,
the flyers and the sabers and I watched the Bruins and the penguins game.
Um,
actually watch the penguins game this morning.
I want you to fucking recording of it.
So I'm all,
I got nothing left.
I can't watch any more fucking sports,
but I have to watch the patriots tonight,
play a cunt face Magoo and the Indianapolis Colts.
And I really hope to patriots win because I really want to hear how Peyton
manning is going to figure out how to complain about Bill Belichick and the
Patriots this year.
That guy's one of the biggest fucking babies in the history of the NFL.
One of the biggest crybabies in the history of the fucking NFL.
They were holding onto our receivers at night.
I couldn't get to Paul to them.
I remember that year he cried about it after the game,
he made a tape.
Okay?
Three weeks later at the pro bowl,
he cried about it.
He quiet about it all the way to the draft.
Now,
if you're ever watching the NFL and you're wondering why is it illegal to cover
receivers now it's because of Peyton manning whining.
He wore a diaper from fucking January until may crying about this fucking game
and then they could run.
I feel like a jerk.
And then what happens?
They make this rule where basically you can't cover receiver and the very next
year he goes out,
not only does he break Dan Marino's touchdown record,
he shatters it.
A record that had been around for 20 years,
you know I had been around for 20 years.
I'll tell you why because you could cover receivers and Dan Marino was the shit.
That's why Dan Marino owns every fucking passing record out there except Brett
Farve decided to play till he was 50 you know Jesus Christ.
If Dan Marino play til he was 50 you never,
you never would occur.
And you couldn't cover receivers that gay.
What a fucking throw 90 touchdowns.
And I hated the Guy Patriots Fan.
He used to kill us all the time and people still give the gun shit cause he
never won a super bowl.
What was he supposed to do?
Tackle people to you fucking morons.
That guy never had a running back.
Dan Marino is the greatest quarterback that ever fucking played.
The game guy was a beast.
Second year in the league he throws for like 5,000 yards.
Who does that?
Nobody.
Nobody does that.
Okay.
So this half retarded Frankenstein is coming in as big Frankenstein fucking
head.
He's coming in there to play the Patriots today.
And I don't know what's going to happen.
You know what's great is I'm recording this before the game happened.
So I gotta,
I gotta talk some Shit here.
What I think's going to happen,
I actually think the cults are going to win.
I think the Patriots' defense is still,
it's too new.
It's too young.
And even though bill Bellacheck is a defense of genius,
and he slowly molding them into that suffocating,
quote unquote boring defense that we had,
remember that the beginning of the two thousands when everybody said the
Patriots were a boring team with no stars on it.
And I take Peyton manning over,
fucking Tom Brady wants to score three super bowls to one.
Rarely you'd rather have fucking one title rather than three.
Well,
good luck to Ya.
So,
um,
I dunno,
I dunno what's gonna happen today,
but,
uh,
I have faith,
I have faith in my boys and I think we're gonna fucking,
uh,
we're going to eke out a victory.
And I think fucking Peyton manning is going to cry about it and he's gonna throw
his team under the bus.
We Hash,
we had from protection issues,
we had protection shoe.
Fucking what a Douche bag.
You know what I mean?
He should go have a sword fight with that fucking idiot kicker.
His all right,
there you go.
That's my prediction.
Um,
anyways,
was there a prediction in there?
Yeah,
I'm,
I'm my heart's saying,
my heart is saying that the Patriots are going to win by three.
My brain is telling me that we might lose by seven just because,
um,
I just,
I,
like I said,
we have a brand new fucking defense and it's going to take them,
believe it or not,
it does take a good year or two for guys to get used to each other to know where
they're going to be at,
you know,
to know where you got help and all that type of shit.
So anyways,
let's continue on with the podcast.
Oh,
let's get into this shit storm.
Last week I did a,
uh,
somebody asked me a question about why when a guy does something,
um,
for his girlfriend,
why is it never enough?
And one of the,
one of the problems that I've had and that this guy had last week as you,
you try to plan something that both you and your girlfriend can enjoy as your
night out.
And evidently women have a problem when you pick something for the both of you
to do that you as a guy will also enjoy evidently from what I'm reading from
these fucking psycho emails that I got this week,
is that if it's not 100% about them,
if you
don't literally make a rose bowl fucking float,
set them on it and then drag it down street with your fucking teeth.
They feel that you got too much and enjoyment out of the evening.
So basically the evening was,
it was really your evening.
It was real.
Look,
look at the fucking wedding day.
You standing up like an idiot and she makes this grand entrance.
She gets some one of a kind dress and you,
you get a Tuxedo that some fucking drunks going to wear at a 15 year anniversary
for a bowling alley the next fucking week.
You know what I mean?
All right,
let's listen to what the twats had to say to this week.
Um,
all right,
hit this,
this,
this wonderful girl.
And I said she's wonderful because she actually admitted that she was a psycho
because I actually emailed her and asked her,
why do you only respond to male,
female shit?
And she sort of in her own little cute way,
admitted that she was a psycho,
so I can't hate her.
But anyways,
this is her email.
Hey Bill,
I love the clueless email questions from your male listeners.
That's always a great way,
by the way,
to get the other people to listen to what you have to say right out of the gate.
Just start insulting them and talking down to them.
Um,
he said,
uh,
the guy was asking why is it never enough to please a woman since he admit he,
um,
and then she's referring to his email.
He,
she says,
since he admits he isn't home a lot,
I'm guessing his wife slash girlfriend is doing all the dirty work for him,
his laundry,
cleaning,
cooking,
picking up after him,
et Cetera.
All right,
let's stop right there.
She's doing all the dirty work.
Let me ask you guys a question.
Would you rather sit home doing laundry?
First of all,
laundry is the most overrated fucking chore ever.
If you have laundry in your fucking apartment,
w that takes all of a minute to load the fucking thing in,
and if you're not colorblind,
it probably takes 45 seconds to load it in and then you go back to watching the
prices,
right?
Cleaning,
cooking,
picking up after him.
I would rather do that than do what this other guy's doing.
This other guy is working like 60 hours a fucking week.
Okay,
well let's,
let's move it.
She's already made this assumption.
Okay?
Then she,
then she wants him to spend some time with him and he comes up with something
that he wanted to do.
Just like when you took your girl girlfriend on that drive.
All we heard about was the love story between you and the car.
You were more excited about the car than anything.
It was like you were on a date with the car and your girlfriend just came along
for the ride.
Listen back to even the tone in your voice when you were talking about it.
It's like you were talking about another woman.
All right.
You know something.
I could sit around for 20 years trying to come up with the perfect paragraph to
talk how insanely jealous and psychotic women are.
Can you be,
they did jealous about an inanimate object.
She's talking about a car.
It's almost like you were talking about another woman lady.
You are out of your fucking mind.
You're out of your fucking mind and you're totally ignoring the fact that I took
her out to dinner.
I took her out to lunch.
I took her up for a ride up to Pacific coast highway.
People fly out here as a vacation to do that.
A lot of couples do that.
And I'll tell you right now,
they don't do it in a corvette convertible.
They do it in like a fucking whatever,
a Buick century.
Really?
I mean,
it literally is never enough.
You're actually proving this guy point,
this guy's points that she says,
my husband does the same damn thing.
I'm like,
what can we do for fun today slash tonight?
And He,
the only thing he can come up with are things that interest him.
Well,
what can you come up with?
Can you come up with anything that doesn't interest yourself?
You're selfish cunt.
You're doing the exact same fucking thing.
And it's unbelievably selfish for you to sit here and,
and,
and have like a,
a day that's for both of you and it has to be 100% about you because what you
did,
some laundry,
you lazy.
Fuck your base.
You know what women are,
they're basically,
they're like adult children.
That's what they are.
They never get beyond their,
like juveniles.
They're adults,
but they still want to be treated like they're not of age.
It's,
it's just fucking boggles my God damn mind.
Um,
she goes,
I'd rather not do anything at all.
I think it's Selfoss and Eggnog and obnoxious that everything we do has to have
his interests before mine.
So everything that they do should have your interests before his,
yeah,
he's fucking broad.
Sarah didn't see this is this is my thing.
This is why you should,
you should never get married.
You should never be in a fucking relationship.
You shouldn't because they just constantly fucking hack away,
itch a goddamn knees.
And their idea of a relationship is that you do everything that they want to do.
And right now they're sitting there shaking their heads.
They're going now.
Now even the girl wrote,
that's probably saying no.
And there's a bunch of other women going like,
I'm not like that.
I went to a ping pong convention.
They always come up with some stupid ass fucking example.
And at the end of the fucking day,
you have to do everything that they do.
The you have to do what the fuck they want to do or else they get mad.
Okay.
And that my friend is when jerking off comes into play because when you really
break it down,
what's the worst thing that they're going to do to you?
They're not going to fuck you for a few days.
Okay.
And I gotta be honest with you,
once you rub one out,
who gives a fuck?
And you have to have that clarity when you're nuts.
A full,
do you know what I mean?
Am I sounding like a fucking maniac here?
I know I am.
But
you got,
you got to hear what the,
with this,
with this other,
this other woman wrote.
And of course I don't have it in front of me because I'm an idiot with a fuck.
It is.
All right.
Um,
I am writing to comment on the wide is never enough discussion on your last
episode episode.
I'll start by saying that the,
that wrote in and to a slightly lesser extent,
you come off as total Douche is,
let me explain my view of the writers.
Okay.
The writer's situation.
Oh,
I guess the guy who sent the email.
Uh,
and yes,
I am one of those manipulatives,
selfish creatures known as women.
Um,
yeah,
you are what you call yourself out on it.
Now Suppose Oran was I supposed to like read that and be like,
wow,
I really am too harsh on women.
Say you're like trying to manipulate me with your fucking bullshit already.
Okay,
here we go.
Um,
I don't remember the names,
so I'll call him Bob and his wife Sally.
Bob Neglect.
Sally.
A huge fuck up on Bob's part.
Now let's,
let's get back to the,
to the detail here.
He's neglecting her.
What does he,
is he out at the bar chasing other women?
This guy is out working his fucking ass off.
This is the thing that women don't understand.
What they don't understand is I,
this is maybe I'm being a moron again or a Douche as this lady says.
I think a lot of women don't understand what it takes to be successful.
What it takes is sacrifice.
And in your 20s,
you have to work your fucking ass off.
That's what I did for five years.
If my first five years in this fucking business,
I had no girlfriend.
I had no social life,
a had nothing,
all I was doing shows and and fucking rubbing one out.
That's what the fuck I did.
Every God damn day I went to work,
I was writing jokes at work and at night I got an a piece of shit car and I
would sometimes drive to another fucking state.
And you know why I had no girlfriend during that time because none of them could
understand what I had to do to get where I am today.
All of them were giving me shit.
You're doing standup again tonight.
Do you realize how many Richard Pryor's are fucking working at a home depot or
Jimi Hendrix?
Because they hooked up with the wrong fucking Twat who talked him out of their
goddamn dream because they didn't want it.
They didn't want to hear it
because they said you needed some sort of responsibility.
This fucking guy is doing the right thing and she's calling him selfish.
He's at work busting his ass trying to get ahead.
So when he's 40 he's not a fucking loser.
And he has and they all want the fucking house.
They all wanted fucking yesterday,
but they don't want to get through the bullshit of it.
They don't want to go through the bullshit of it where you actually have to uh,
not see him for a little while because he's out working.
So anyways,
huge fuck up on his fart part to be a busting his goddamn ass.
So he says Bob Decides to make it up to her by taking her to see your live show,
she says,
which is awesome.
And a dinner,
which is pretty standard.
This is how out of control women are.
She's getting a free fucking meal
and they're so spoiled as a sex that she's describes a free fucking meal as
standard.
Do you know what I have to do as a man to get a free meal?
I have to like when like a fucking,
like a radio contest,
you know,
I got to call up this radio station and imitate the local sports guy and I have
to beat out all these other fucking guys who are,
I haven't had a free meal since I was like eight years old.
My parents took me to Mcdonald's or whatever,
like maybe 13,
14 women are so fucking spoiled that this guy is busting his ass at work that's
viewed as selfish.
He's buying this girl a free dinner and it's viewed as standard.
They're out of their fucking minds.
So anyway,
she goes,
Sally basically tells her friends who may or may not know that Bob has been
fucking up.
Once again,
Bob is fucking up because he's busting his acid work.
So when they're 40,
they're going to be uneasy street.
He's fucking up right now.
Um,
the same bitches who make your fucking,
you know,
not chase your dream,
leave you when you're 38 because you're a fucking loser.
Right.
All right.
I love generalizing.
It really gets these twats cunt hairs in a fucking to,
I can't even finish that sentence.
That was so evil.
All right,
let's plan it's flower head.
Um,
who may or may not know that Bob has been fucking up that this night out is not
what she had in mind,
but she is taking what she can get playing the victim are the poor baby.
She's taking what?
She got a free meal.
She's just taken what she can get and she's getting a show to come out to my
show when of the best fucking comedians in the country.
You like Dad,
I'm talking shit.
It's football Sunday and I'm a plus.
I'm reading the ric Flair,
the best comic on the biggest hill.
Um,
anyways,
uh,
Bob gets upset and determines that no one has ever or will ever be able to
please any female code for why should he even make an effort to make his wife
happy in their marriage?
That's not code for that.
That's how you read into it.
You've never met Bob.
You've made all kinds of assumptions here.
Poor,
poor Bob.
Bob's do.
Sherry becomes a crystal,
becomes crystal clear when he is,
when he says something to the effect of this whole night outs was supposed to be
about her.
This is a,
this is classic male privilege wankery but I realize this is hard for you and
Bob to see.
So I'm here to help.
Um,
I'll try to make it simple.
When you piss off your wife bringing her along to a show you already wanted to
go to and that she is only mildly interested in.
Then being a little scroll them about it when she's is underwhelmed by the fact
that you are actually making an effort to go out with her,
which is what you should have been doing as a matter of course is not the way to
go.
Oh my God.
I mean the arrogance in this,
I love people who are arrogant and the calling you out for being arrogant,
bringing to her to a show.
Do you understand like,
I'm going to stop being a jerk here because maybe I can actually convince a
couple of women,
do you understand what it takes?
This is what actually,
you know,
I've been generalizing,
there are women out there who understand what it takes to become successful and
I guarantee you most of them are not in relationships and they have a difficult
time being in relationships.
You know,
because the guy that with wants to go home and play fucking footsie or once her
around and doesn't understand that these are the years where she has to bust her
ass to get where the fuck she's going to be.
You know?
So Lady,
both of you guys are a hundred percent wrong.
I could see if this guy was out drinking with his buddies,
if this guy was out fucking around on her or if he was just sitting there
staring at the TV watching football and not paying attention to her when he
brings her out.
Yeah.
Then I could see that he should have some sort of mini all about your wedding
day for her.
Okay.
But if this guy is busting his ass at fucking work,
okay,
he's not going out having a good time either.
So he should be allowed to have some sort of enjoyment.
You don't understand.
He should be able to enjoy some of the day,
some of the night also,
and this is nothing that you haven't even brought up.
How much of the rent do you think he's fucking pain?
I'd be willing to bet that he's paying more than she is.
A lot of guys are in that situation too.
When you get this,
the adult child version of a fucking woman,
I'm telling you,
you women,
I'm telling you the two who wrote in your way out of line on this one.
I'm not even trying to be funny right now.
You're 100% in the fucking wrong here.
You're being selfish beyond fucking selfish.
This guy is at work.
He's busting his ass trying to get ahead.
Do you think this guy wants to fucking work 60 hours a week?
Nobody dreams about doing that.
Why do you think he's doing that?
He's trying to become successful,
you know,
so the next time you're gay,
I like I said,
if this guy had been fucking around or if this guy had been sitting there
watching you know,
sports and not paying attention to you and hadn't given you a compliment since
you could fucking remember.
Yeah,
then I could understand,
you know what I mean?
Taking you to the whatever the fuck you want it to go to,
but for you to sit there and this guy spends is harder and fucking money takes
you out to dinner.
Okay.
Which you got to understand is not standard.
In your home.
How fucking spoiled to you that you think that that is stick is standard.
I got the fucking hiccups here.
I'm so God damn upset.
Um,
you guys are,
you guys are 100% wrong.
And if any you broads out there one on one to try to come out and support these
two girls.
I mean go for it because I don't see how they're wrong.
This guy did nothing wrong.
He took her out to go see a show.
It's just,
you know,
what is stand up.
Comedy is not respected.
It isn't if he took you out to see a Broadway show or a fucking musical or are,
I guess that's the same thing.
I Dunno what,
I guess if he took you out for dinner and a movie.
I love [inaudible] like,
like guys always have to show some sort of imagination.
It's standard.
It was just imagination.
We like the prizes and it's like,
when was the last time your girl actually showed any fucking imagination when
they got you a shirt,
you know,
or some sports DVD you did they
ever really show any sort of fucking imagination?
I'll tell you what does my girl,
she actually showed some imagination one year when I first met her,
I uh,
I was playing drums,
you know,
she knew I was in a drum.
She knew I loved them and she actually got me this pair of drum.
So you gave me a pair of drum sticks and we don't even go on off for like a
month.
So there was like that thing,
you can't get a really huge gift,
but you got to get him some.
She got me a pair of drum sticks and she had my,
my initials engraved in them.
I never even used them.
I thought it was really,
it was unique.
It was loving it.
We didn't know and it didn't cost that much money and it was totally fucking
cool.
I wouldn't be like,
well,
you know,
that's,
you got to do that every birthday.
You know,
surprise me like you did with the drum sticks at sects.
Spend a ton of fucking money to,
you know,
I didn't know if that even fucking,
I think I started to make one point and then I made another one in that one.
I'm so fucking annoyed by these.
These women did,
and they're there.
They're out of their fucking minds.
You're out of your fucking minds.
Okay?
If the guy who wrote that email last week don't listen to these fucking twats,
all right,
you bought,
you're out there,
you're busting your goddamn ass.
You have to sit down and you have to explain to your wife or your girlfriend or
whatever the fuck she is,
what it takes to become successful because I'm telling you,
you understand what it is you're doing,
what everybody else did in their 20s all those people out there,
you know the broads with the tramp stamps and the guys with the tribal band
tattoo who are out there doing keg stands and fucking everything that moves,
doing their best to catch herpes every fucking weekend.
Those people,
they wonder what happens when they're getting their thirties and forties they
wonder what the fuck happened.
You know?
And they're looking at you like you're a shithead.
Now the payoff is,
is usually when you become successful,
you end up running a corvette at 41
having sort of a mini midlife crisis.
But I'm telling you,
I'd rather be me than those other fucking dudes.
I really would.
So you really need to explain to this woman who looks at you busting your ass as
neglect,
as,
as being selfish.
It's just beyond me.
It's fucking beyond.
You're doing what you're supposed to be doing as a man is a man is supposed to
work and he's supposed to provide for his family.
And what you are doing is you are laying the groundwork for you to do that as
best as you possibly can.
And for someone to say that that is selfish,
it's just fucking beyond me.
Okay.
Let me ask you this.
When you went out that night,
how fucking tired were you?
How many times did you yawn from working all fucking week?
You know what I mean?
You know,
aren't you allowed to go out and have a good time with your girlfriend,
with a little bit of Shit that she enjoys?
A little bit of stuff that,
that you enjoy?
Isn't that like a fucking relationship?
I mean,
am I out of my fucking mind here
anyways?
Um,
this is really just to become a,
uh,
a woman bashing thing.
This is really just fucking tapped into.
This is another email I got bill.
This,
this got me so pissed off and I swear the first thing that came to my mind was
wait till bill,
here's this shit.
Um,
I guess I listened to your show too much.
So here's the story.
He goes,
I went on my lunch break with the female coworker today,
and the true mind of a female really shined.
I'm telling you a women,
you really got to chime in here and,
and trash guys because this is really becoming,
this is like,
like the guys this week or Stanford and women are fucking USC.
But uh,
whatever,
watch Oprah.
You always went on that show.
Here we go.
Uh,
first off,
I'm not interested in this female.
Uh,
we are just friends.
We have,
we've even talked about this and I've explained to her and we agree.
Nothing is happening there.
No problem.
Uh,
so we go out to get a sandwich and her ATM account is frozen.
She calls the bank and they think something's wrong and won't give her the money
to they talk tomorrow.
Right there.
Fuck the banks.
Right,
exactly.
You can't even get your own fucking money.
Um,
provided she's not overdrawn.
So here we go.
So he goes,
I would have lent her the cash,
but I was broke.
I offered to give her all the money,
all the money in my pocket,
about $2 and 50 cents in pocket change that would at least bought her a coffee.
I already paid for my sandwich,
uh,
when we found out about the ATM.
So she turns down that,
but asked me to drive her a few blocks to go to the bank and I happily do,
um,
that doesn't work and we have to go back to work.
This is all during your lunch hour.
Um,
she asked me to borrow a credit card,
is something to get food.
I don't have any.
So she can't.
So she calls back the job in the ass.
Another guy for five bucks.
He says,
yes.
Uh,
she then asked me for the two 50.
She turned down before.
I said,
sure,
now here is the fucking kicker.
So now this girl has seven 50.
She then tells me word for word.
Well,
since I got five bucks,
now let me tell you something.
And with this fake grin on her face trying to soften the blow,
actually she wasn't.
She's going into cut mode here.
She goes,
uh,
if you were in this jam,
I would have offered you half of my sandwich.
But that's okay.
I'm just saying.
And the guy said,
I was floored.
I was like,
Yo,
first off,
you only said this after you got the money because you knew how it might make me
feel and now you have my money and don't need my sandwich.
So basically you just wanted to make me feel shitty for not living up to your
standard of friendship.
She laughed it off and said,
uh,
she was trying to offend me.
She wasn't trying to friend me and let it go.
Bullshit.
You called her out on her shit.
Notice how she waited till she got your two 50,
and then did the little s fucking two point reversal on you.
Then she brings it up again and now I realize she was really bothered by the
fact I didn't offer the sandwich I bought with my last five bucks to my name.
Meanwhile,
she,
uh,
she has 400 bucks in the,
they just won't give it to her tomorrow.
She will be fine.
I will still be broke yet she still thinks I should have given her half of the
last sandwich I can for a week till I get paid.
And the thing that gets me the most is we work a labor job.
I'm always helping her lift and move things because she herself brings up the
point.
She is a girl,
yet she talks all the time about how men and women are,
um,
are equal in the workplace and she should be treated the same.
And this isn't some dumb cunt.
She went to school for four years,
got a degree,
changed your mind and now she's going back to get another degree.
They will take her six more year years.
She reads and studies all day.
And I enjoy your conversations because she's smart.
But at the end of the day,
I have learned she's still a woman and she still feels she should somehow be
baby by other men simply because she is a woman.
I'm not sleeping with her.
We had just friends.
Why do you feel entitled to half of my last,
even if after I go out of my way,
um,
oh half of my sandwich.
Even if after I go out of my way every way I can to help you.
Exactly.
You went,
you gave her every last cent in your fucking pants.
You drove her down to the bank,
you drove her back to work.
This was all during your fucking lunch hour.
You're lifting her boxes and all that type of shit.
I mean,
I dunno.
I Dunno what to tell you.
I mean maybe you could have given her half your fucking sandwich.
I haven't,
I don't know what your relationship is with her,
but that's the classic,
you know,
I could see if she got the $5 out of the other guy,
you know and didn't take your two 50 but she gets to five and then takes you to
50 and then brings it up.
You know what I mean?
I'm telling you dude.
Right.
Then like I like if someone did that to me,
I would be done with them.
I will be done with them.
I wouldn't tell him that it would be done with them.
What I would do,
it was I would wait for the next time she needed me to lift something.
Um,
I would do a country smile back to her and be like,
you know,
if I was asking you,
I would make sure that I would live half the box with me,
you know,
or whatever the fuck you want to say.
Um,
anyways.
And he said,
thanks for letting me vent.
Signed the Jewish dude.
Um,
all right,
let's see here.
I think that might be it.
That's it,
right?
I think that is it.
That is it for the podcast.
All right,
well let me say it.
Let me state for the record here.
Um,
I dunno,
after the second time reading that maybe you could have given her half you San
or party his sandwich offered her a bite,
but uh,
you know,
you spent all your fucking money,
then she finds out she's fucking broke.
But that is the typical female fucking thing.
Okay.
Where are equal Rico?
Rescue me,
rescue me.
We're equal.
Rescue me.
They basically,
they ride that fence.
Okay.
And what most of them do is when it's a good thing to be equal,
then your equal.
And when it's a bad thing to be equal,
like you know,
I to pick up something
heavy then,
then it's like,
oh,
I'm just a girl,
you know,
or dinner comes along and the check comes along.
Then I'm a female.
He should be a gentleman.
I did a bit about this a long fucking time ago.
Um,
so basically they can't hit,
I mean,
what are they doing that's wrong there?
They're just trying to manipulate the situation to their advantage.
All you have to do as a guy,
just be conscious of it and call them out on this shit.
Um,
you should have asked for you to 50 back when she said no.
He should have demonstrated your strength as a man.
Tipped her upside down and shook it out of her.
Um,
that's it.
That's it for the Monday morning podcast.
That was kind of dark.
That was kind of evil is kind of ugly and I anticipate a lot of emails,
but,
uh,
that's how the podcast goes sometimes.
And,
uh,
I know it wasn't on a cell phone,
but a go fuck yourself.
That's how I'm doing them.
That's how I'm going to continue doing them.
If you don't like it,
fucking go listen to the old ones.
Go listen to the old bunch of pricks.
Um,
this week I'm going to be at the Improv in Tempe,
Arizona.
All right.
I'm going to be there on Thursday,
Friday and Saturday.
And uh,
there's been a little switcheroo on my schedule.
I was supposed to be going to Seattle.
I was supposed to be going to Seattle to play giggles comedy club,
but I'm unfortunately that comedy club does not advertise.
So the only way I sell tickets is to go on this one particular radio show and
they changed the format and got rid of my hookup up there.
So there's no way for me to go into town to lend anybody know that I'm going to
be there.
So the club owner would just lose a ton of fucking money.
So like a class guy,
I switched out the date.
Okay.
So basically I think I'm going to be maybe doing Seattle in January.
So instead of going to a giggles in Seattle,
I will be at the punchline in Sacramento,
California,
uh,
punchlines Sacramento,
California on December 10th,
11th and 12th and 13th.
And uh,
the week before that I will be at hilarity and Cleveland.
Um,
go to [inaudible] Dot Com B u r r for all the dates and I can't believe I forgot
to mention this at the top of the podcast,
tickets are on sale for a my neck stand up.
Um,
one hour stand up,
a comedy special.
Um,
it's going to be at the Fillmore on December 17th in San Francisco,
California.
If you would like to come.
Uh,
shit,
I don't have any of the fucking information.
I am a goddamn worst.
Do I have the link?
I didn't have the link on my website.
I am the fucking worse.
Go to live nation.com.
That's where the tickets are being sold.
Just type in Bill Burr,
um,
December 17th at the Fillmore.
You will be able to find it.
Um,
or you can join my mailing list because I know I sent out a,
I sent out information about that.
I'm the worst.
All right,
I'll have all the information next week or I'll,
I'll be putting a bulletin up on my,
uh,
my billboard.com on my page.
Oh,
and the other thing I forgot to tell you is I have a uninformed radio.com.
Okay.
Is the new website for the uninformed show?
I believe that's it.
Let me try and,
uh,
once again,
I'm the fucking worst.
I don't have any of the information.
[inaudible] hang on a second.
Fucking voices going way up here.
Hang on everybody who are fans of the uninformed show with bill burr and Joe de
Rosa.
Everybody has asked me for the longest times.
Where can I get the shows?
Uh,
what did we do?
Okay.
Uninformed radio.com.
Yeah.
If you go there,
you can download all the shows and they're going to be for free.
So if you'd like to hear more of me running my fucking mouth,
you can go.
They're uninformed.
radio.com.
That is it.
All.
You guys have a great week and I'll talk to you Monday.
Let's see.
Well,
let's just keep,
what is your mind meeting?
Well done.
The little dude who
you pulled them up,
it
won't be in
the city.
They put,
oh,
well,
the,
we do Tom based on that day.
[inaudible]
no.